y también le quiero felicitar a mi
colega embajadores volcán buscar que ha
tomado la presidencia de la asamblea
general el embajador oscar y su elección
con la elección de mayoría de países del
mundo es una muestra de su experiencia
como político y diplomático y su
confianza como los primeros ciudadanos
de turquía han tomado las posiciones más
altas en el sistema de la onu
creo que el embajador goltz carlos era
la voz y conciencia en esta comunidad
internacional no tengo duda que llevar a
cabo su tarea de manera transparente
buscar el éxito
tomado en esta en este aniversario 75 de
la fundación de la onu creo que llevará
a cabo esta cumbre por el
multilateralismo y la lucha contra el
kobe es una decisión correcta nosotros
estamos determinados a mantener nuestro
apoyo en la lucha contra el joven 19 la
pandemia todo llegó al mundo cuando ya
teníamos dificultades enfrentando
distintos retos la globalización las
reglas internacionales y el
multilateralismo que ya eran sujetos de
discusiones ahora están siendo
cuestionadas por el impacto de la
pandemia cuando miramos lo que ocurre
frente a nosotros tenemos que ver y
evaluar de manera sincera
la parte vacía del vaso en la parte
vacía existe la necesidad de una reforma
para unas organizaciones multilaterales
en particular las naciones unidas'
hemos visto cómo de qué manera tan
efectiva estos mecanismos han trabajado
durante la pandemia y ha tomado meses
para que el consejo de seguridad tome
las decisiones necesarias para incluir
la pandemia en su agenda al principio de
la pandemia
los países quedaron por sí mismos y aquí
de nuevo hemos visto
el hecho de que el mundo es más grande
que estos 5
integrantes de la humanidad no puede
quedar a la merced de un grupo limitado
de países y para que evitar que esas
organizaciones pierdan reputación
tenemos que revisar nuestra mentalidad
nuestras instituciones y nuestras reglas
el multilateralismo efectivo se requiere
también es de instituciones efectivas
tenemos que implementar rápidamente
reformas significativas iniciando con la
reestructuración del consejo de
seguridad
debemos dar el consejo una estructura
más transparente y democrática y debemos
fortalecer también la asamblea general
que refleja la conciencia de la
comunidad internacional mirando la parte
llena del vaso naciones unidas mantiene
el potencial de ser un punto de
inflexión en la búsqueda de la paz la
justicia y la prosperidad
considerando que aún no hemos superado
la crisis de la pandemia debemos tratar
de utilizar las instituciones y
mecanismos que tenemos para la
cooperación multilateral de manera
efectiva donde los problemas son
globales las soluciones locales sólo
pueden aportar hasta cierto punto la
solidaridad internacional es algo
esencial para las soluciones a largo
plazo en turquía desde los primeros días
del brote hemos hecho un llamado a la
cooperación en todas las plataformas
internacionales
hemos estado al frente de los esfuerzos
para combatir la pandemia en el g20 en
el consejo
en la organización de la cooperación
islámica y otras plataformas hemos hecho
un llamado a 146 países y diferentes
organizaciones que pidieron equipos y
asistencia para asegurar un amigo en
estos tiempos tan inciertos con estas
operaciones que hemos llevado a cabo
aseguramos el regreso de más de 100.000
de nuestros ciudadanos en 141 países a
sus hogares con los mismos abuelos
llevamos a extranjeros a sus respectivas
naciones no hicimos todas estas cosas
con la intención de llevar a cabo una
diplomacia al coronavirus aún no
esperamos ningún tipo de compensación
por nuestra ayuda y nuestros esfuerzos
de repatriación estando con las víctimas
y con los oprimidos es lo que corre por
las venas de nuestra nación y lo que
está en la esencia de nuestra política
exterior humanitaria de nuevo hago un
llamado al suministro de equipos médicos
medicamentos y desarrollo de vacunas
para que estos no se hagan como un tema
de competencia
sin importar donde se produzcan las
vacunas deben ser listas y deben ser
hechas para el beneficio de la humanidad
queridos delegados con la pandemia de
nuevo hemos experimentado juntos como
los elementos vitales como la capacidad
estatal y el gobierno y la resistencia y
la resiliencia son detrás de la historia
de éxito de turquía se están los
mecanismos de gobierno efectivos una
alta capacidad desarrollada por nuestras
inversiones en salud y recursos humanos
calificados
como la verdad
sin embargo la pandemia de año para
y ciertas cosas alrededor del mundo y
aumentó las vulnerabilidades lamentamos
que el secretario general haya hecho un
llamado a un cese al fuego que nosotros
de hecho también apoyamos y que no ha
regenerado los resultados deseados
en turquía estamos buscando maneras de
eliminar amenazas a nuestro país y
también para la humanidad tomando
cualquier tipo de iniciativa en caso de
ser necesario el conflicto en siria que
entró en su décimo año sigue
representando una amenaza para la
seguridad y estabilidad regional con el
país
el mayor ataque y el más certero contra
y si continuamos luchando contra el pkk
esta organización terrorista mientras la
comunidad internacional no podemos
encontrar una
solución
[Música]
en contra de todas las organizaciones
terroristas
este enfoque también es esencial para
asegurar
que la seguridad regrese hacia el
regreso de más de 400 11.000 hermanos y
hermanas de siria de regiones que hemos
liberado de organizaciones terroristas
en siria es el mayor indicador de esto
gracias a las regiones que aseguramos
logramos que millones de sirios que
viven diferentes partes del país
particularmente en it link se hayan ido
de su tierra natal
turquía recibe a cerca de 4 millones de
sirios
y atiende todas sus necesidades también
cumplimos con las necesidades de cerca
en la mayor cantidad de sirios en las
regiones que hemos mantenido bajo
nuestro control especialmente en áreas
cercanas a nuestra frontera finalmente
estamos construyendo decenas de miles de
hogares en el clima y en otras partes
para nuestros hermanos y hermanas
llevamos a cabo todas estas actividades
con nuestros propios medios y el apoyo
de nuestro pueblo sin un apoyo
significativo de la comunidad
internacional o de organizaciones
internacionales
debería ser una prioridad que todos
nosotros podamos resolver el conflicto
en siria
y bajo la hoja de ruta
la resolución 24 522 54 el proceso
político iniciado
en las naciones unidas que también
es liderado por siria debería ser
llevado a una conclusión exitosa
esta es la única manera en que siria
puede lograr una paz duradera
manteniendo su integridad territorial y
su unidad política hasta que este
objetivo se ha logrado estamos
determinados a evitar que organizaciones
terroristas que tratan de amenazar
nuestra seguridad nacional así como otra
como la
integridad política y territorial de
siria países como turquía que están
recibiendo la mayor cantidad de
refugiados han salvado la dignidad de
toda la humanidad a través de sus
propios sacrificios sin embargo o
algunos estados incluyendo algunos
países europeos desafortunadamente
violan los derechos de los refugiados y
de quienes buscan asilo este momento
para que naciones unidas tome se levante
de manera firme ante estas violaciones
que van en contra de la comisión de
ginebra y del sistema de derechos
humanos
lo que ocurre en libia el año pasado
para tratar de acabar con el gobierno de
acuerdo nacional solamente ha traído
dolor y sufrimiento a ese país
y la comunidad internacional
no pudo asegurar que las presiones que
apoyaban a quienes apoyaban el golpe de
estado hayan acabado las masacres las
violaciones de los derechos humanos y
también las fosas comunes al taj una
turquía ha sido el único país que ha
dado una respuesta concreta al llamado
de ayuda del gobierno legítimo de libia
creemos que una solución permanente en
libia puede ser establecida a través de
un proceso de diálogo integral liderado
por los libios
también está bajo la responsabilidad de
la comunidad internacional detener el
derramamiento de sangre en yemen que ha
continuado por más de 5 años y también
detener la crisis humanitaria la
historia no va a perdonar a aquellos que
acaban con la unidad política y la
soberanía la integridad política en
yemen con la intención de ganar
poder en la región a pesar del
sufrimiento de los yemeníes es nuestro
deseo que irak no se convierte en una
zona de guerra y de conflicto para
poderes externos
que más bien puedan tener prosperidad
para la región aunque apoyamos a nuestro
vecino irak que en cada campo queremos
colaborar de manera cercana sobre todo
en la lucha contra el terrorismo
esperamos una cooperación en william por
parte de la comunidad internacional
en contra de la organización terrorista
del pkk que también ha estado en irak
así como ha sido el caso para el daes
liberar la región de estas
organizaciones terroristas va a
contribuir al futuro de irak que tiene
la geografía más antigua de la humanidad
y queremos resolver los temas del
programa nuclear de irán según la ley
internacional a través de la diplomacia
y el diálogo quiero reiterar nuestro
llamado a los países para que siguen las
obligaciones del acuerdo nuclear que
contribuye la seguridad global y la
presión en palestina que es la herida de
la humanidad sigue dañando nuestras
conciencias la mano sucia que
llega a la privacidad de jerusalén ya
donde coexisten tres grandes religiones
aumenta cada vez más
el pueblo palestino se ha levantado en
contra de las políticas israelíes de
opresión violencia y de intimidación por
más de medio siglo el documento se trató
de imponer un documento de rendición
llamado el acuerdo del siglo israel
aumentó sus ataques a la con ayuda de
sus colaboradores
turquía no va a apoyar ningún plan que
el pueblo palestino no le haya dado su
consenso la participación de algunos
países regionales no significa nada más
allá de servir los esfuerzos de israel
para erosionar los parámetros
internacionales países que han declarado
su intención de abrir sus embajadas en
jerusalén en violación de las
resoluciones de la onu y de la ley
internacional sólo hacen que el
conflicto se complique más con sus
acciones
y el conflicto palestino sólo puede
resolverse con el establecimiento de un
estado soberano de palestina basado en
las fronteras del 67 con el este de
jerusalén con capital buscar soluciones
diferentes a estas van en vano son
unilaterales e injustas quienes atacaron
los territorios azerbaiyanos en julio
han probado de nuevo que es el mayor
obstáculo para la paz duradera y la
estabilidad
en esa zona estamos a favor de resolver
los conflictos de manera rápida en línea
con la soberanía territorial de
azerbaiyán y georgia georgia
[Música]
el conflicto de cachemira que también es
clave para la estabilidad del sur de
asia sigue siendo un tema candente los
pasos tomados después de la audición de
jammú y cachemira
han complicado aún más la cuestión
estamos a favor de resolver este tema a
través del diálogo
bajo las resoluciones de la onu y en
línea con las expectativas del pueblo de
casi 1000
queridos delgados
detrás de las tensiones que existen en
el mediterráneo del este hay países
que propone la situación de el ganador
se lleva todo
y tratar de escribir en nuestro país no
tiene ningún tipo de posibilidad de
ganar tenemos un interés en el
mediterráneo oriental ni ninguna otra
región sin embargo no podemos darle la
espalda a los derechos de nuestro país y
de los turcos chipriotas para que sean
ignorados la razón para que esos
problemas que existe en la región
son los pasos unilaterales que han
tomado por los chipriotas y por los
griegos con sus máximas demandas turquía
es un país que está
que quieren contrarrestar los
desarrollos negativos en esta región del
mediterráneo oriental por otra parte
ignorar a nuestro país cuando se trata
de los recursos naturales en la región
no puede explicarse por conciencia o por
sabiduría ni por en ley internacional
nuestra prioridad es arreglar las
disputas a través de un diálogo sincero
basados en la ley internacional y de una
base equitativa
sin embargo quisiera decir claramente
que nunca vamos a tolerar ninguna
imposición ninguna cosa o ataque en la
dirección opuesta
quisiera repetir aquí nuestro llamado
para establecer el diálogo y la
cooperación entre los países de la costa
del mediterráneo oriental en este
propósito queremos proponer una
conferencia regional incluyendo a los
turcos chipriotas donde se consideren
las peticiones de cada país
una de las razones para la crisis en la
región es la ausencia de una solución
integral al tema de chipre durante las
negociaciones que han continuado desde
el 68 el único obstáculo para una
solución es la falta de compromiso y el
enfoque que han tomado los chipriotas
ignorar los tratados internacionales
ellos tratan de hacer que los turcos
chipriotas sean una minoría o tratar
incluso de excluirlos totalmente de la
isla
como un país garante nunca hemos dejado
a los turcos chipriotas solos en su
causa justa y no los vamos a dejar
tampoco en el futuro la solución para
este tema de chipre es posible solamente
aceptando el hecho de que los turcos
chipriotas
también comparten la propiedad de esta
isla
vamos a apoyar cualquier solución que
apoye la seguridad del pueblo turco
chipriota así como sus derechos
políticos e históricos en la región
distinguidos delegados
este año marca el 75 aniversario de las
bombas en hiroshima y nagasaki asegurar
la paz depende de acabar con este tipo
de armamento en contraste la
arquitectura del control de armas ha
sufrido un daño significativo en años
recientes y la comunidad internacional
debe avanzar en la base de la equidad y
la justicia con respecto a este tema
eliminando todo tipo de armas de
destrucción masiva otro tema importante
donde tenemos una obligación importante
para actuar es el cambio climático vemos
como la interferencia humana en el
balance de la naturaleza puede llevar a
un gran costo
debemos acabar y dar reversa en este en
esta dirección errónea como turquía
apoyamos los esfuerzos
y cumplimos con nuestras obligaciones
aunque
tenemos una gran responsabilidad en este
momento en el pasado reciente recibimos
la conferencia de las partes de las
partes para la convención para combatir
la desertificación hemos llevado a cabo
una cooperación con diferentes países
especialmente en áfrica también tomamos
la responsabilidad de atender la
conferencia para la diversidad biológica
quiero llamar su atención para un
problema que amenaza a la humanidad pero
que por alguna razón se considera
invisible el racismo la xenofobia la
islamofobia y el discurso de odio han
llegado a un discurso ha llegado a un
nivel alarmante durante la pandemia los
actos de violencia contra personas
vulnerables incluyendo personas que
buscan asilo refugiados inmigrantes se
han acelerado así como también la
xenofobia y el racismo los musulmanes
están son los más expuestos a estas
tendencias peligrosas alentadas por el
prejuicio y la ignorancia
aquellos que son primeros responsables
son los políticos que acuden al
populismo en busca de votos y aquellos
que les imitan este tipo de discurso
atacando la libertad de expresión
hago un llamado urgente a todas las
organizaciones internacionales para que
tomen pasos concretos en la lucha contra
esta mentalidad
y reitero mi llamado para el marzo 15
el día del ataque en nueva zelanda
contra musulmanes para que sea declarado
por la onu como el día internacional de
la solidaridad contra la islamofobia
como la segunda organización más grande
después de naciones unidas la
organización de cooperación islámica ha
reconocido oficialmente ya este día
las pandemias y la crisis la sociedad
con ella también tiene efectos negativos
en el desarrollo sostenible y en los
objetivos de 2030
los países en desarrollo y los países de
bajos ingresos son los más afectados por
esta crisis de hecho lo que ha ocurrido
durante la pandemia nos ha mostrado que
el desarrollo sostenible y sus objetivos
pueden ser una guía a la hora de
combatir todo tipo de crisis globales
deberíamos utilizar el poder de la
digitalización para
ayudar a estos países a sobrevivir a la
crisis apoyamos
la hoja de ruta para la cooperación
digital propuesta por el secretario
general y también tenemos el tema del
foro de la diplomacia que hemos diseñado
para atender temas regionales a medida
que la diploma como tema de la
diplomacia en la era digital
también recibimos
y tecnología bancaria para los países
menos desarrollados
y
ser
esta es la posición que está turquía
aumenta nuestra influencia en diferentes
áreas con esta iniciativa vamos a darle
a nuestras relaciones con asia
un nuevo ímpetu cuando el péndulo de la
historia se mueve de nuevo hacia asia
también hemos mejorado nuestras
relaciones con áfrica con quien tenemos
nexos y lazos humanitarios que conectan
nuestras geografías
pensamos fortalecer la capacidad
africana
en la tercera cumbre que llevaremos a
cabo en turquía el próximo año y
mientras concluyo mi declaración
quisiera decir que el apoyo por el
multilateralismo continuará durante este
periodo sensible que estamos atravesando
debemos por supuesto mantener nuestra
distancia
no debemos alejarnos del tema de la
pandemia pero debemos cooperar ante
todos los retos que amenazan a la
comunidad internacional
y continuaremos con nuestros esfuerzos
para transformar a estambul una de las
ciudades más prometedoras del mundo en
un hub regional a través de las naciones
unidas- deseó éxito en estos trabajos de
la asamblea número 75 los saludo con
respeto en nombre mío y de mi nación les
deseo la mejor de la salud